Well, Walmart is making big commitments...
...to places like 1888 Mills in Griffin, Georgia...
...who make the finest towels around.
You see, towels are made from cotton.
And cotton is grown right here in the US.
It's just good business to manufacture the towels...
...near where you grow the cotton.
Walmart's commitment allowed 1888 Mills to raise the capital...
...to invest in more equipment, capacity, and of course, more workers,...
...which made making towels here in America good for business.
Now multiply that times the hundreds of US factories working with Walmart.
That could mean up to 1 million new manufacturing and service jobs...
...in communities across the country over the next ten years.
That's a lot of jobs,...
...which means more people have more money to spend on products that support American jobs...
At places like, well, Walmart...
...that demand for those products means more work for American factories.
And all of a sudden, you've got yourself some real job creation and real economic growth.